- Congratulations on your
Golden Globe nomination.
- [Ben] Thank you very much.
- That's so cool.
(audience applauding)
I have to say Snoop announcing
it was my favorite part.
I want you to see it unless you missed it.
- [Ben] That was nice, yeah.
- Ben Affleck.
Ben Affleck, my fault.
(audience laughing quietly)
Sorry about that, Ben.
- (laughing) He got the
emphasis a little off.
It was a little...
- He did get the emphasis
a little off, yeah.
It's funny, because I always
grew up and I thought,
Affleck, what an incredibly ugly name.
Now, it sounds like the duck commercial.
- Affleck.
- Yes, I know, isn't that funny?
- Yes, you're the first person to say it.
- When I was a kid, my parents,
I always remember them,
the old days when people would call you up
for a magazine subscription or something,
and they'd go, "A, F as
in Frank, F as in Frank."
And I was always like, why
do they always do that?
And I realized, as I started
looking through the mail,
we would get, and it would always be like,
Mr. And Mrs. A-S-S-L-I-C-K.
And I was like, I see.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- [Ben] You hate to
have that misunderstood.
- You hate it.
You hate to see it.
Love that you didn't say
it on daytime TV, 'cause...
- Spelled it out, because
people can't read.
- [Kelly] Yeah, read it aloud to yourself.